so what do programmers actually do let's
look at the wiki definition of a
programmer computer programmer is a
person that creates computer software
and what is computer software computer
software is a set of data or computer
instructions that tell the computer what
to do let's take Wikipedia as an example
Wikipedia needs software engineers to
make sure that when you and I open the
same article to edit it we can actually
collaborate on it and this changes that
you made one be erased when I click the
safe or added button Wikipedia needs a
set of software engineers to maintain
its databases all over the world because
believe it or not wikipedia has around 6
million articles so we need to make sure
that all that can be maintained and be
robust Wikipedia needs to make sure that
the front end of the website looks the
way the designers have implemented so it
needs a set of front-end engineers to do
that Wikipedia also needs to make sure
that when you I millions of people
around the world open millions and
millions of articles Wikipedia doesn't
crash it's fast and it's able to
maintain that huge auto load software
engineers solve problems and to solve a
problem ax they use coding as a tool so
essentially software engineers are
problem solvers and to solve a problem
at the programmer needs to understand
the problem they need to understand the
context around the problem they very
much need to understand the constraints
of the system surrounding the problem
and they of course deeply need to
understand why they're solving the
problem they're solving
might go something like this I work as a
software engineer at Airbnb and let's
say Airbnb wants to develop the wish
list feature to develop this wishlist
feature I as a back-end engineer would
be responsible for all the underlying
logic that you the user do not see but
that is how the system works so when you
heart a house on Airbnb I need to make
sure that this house is going to be
associated with the wish list list that
you as a user create and that this list
in and of itself needs to be associated
with my user accounts and that this list
is going to be saved in the database the
house will be saved
in the list in the database and
associated with my accounts I need to
make sure that when you're on Harts the
house it's going to be removed from my
wish list and removed from the
association with my user accounts all
that is what I as a back-end engineer
would be responsible for a front-end
engineer will work closely with me
because they need to know what is the
underlying logic for this feature as
well as when the designer will propose
the designs of how it will actually look
like on the platform and then all of us
together will also work probably with
the data scientist because a data
scientist will actually analyze houses
successful was this feature should
should it be something that we should
keep on the platform so we would
implement logging to track how popular
the feature is how many users use it are
they happy with it is the button color
all right so all of us will work as a
team on this
I hope this sheds some light on what
programmers actually do and these
like this video don't forget to like and
subscribe leave any comments down below
put the notification buttons on to know
when the new content is coming and I
hope you guys have a wonderful wonderful
day bye for now
you